last week someone sent me this clip that
went viral of a coffee dispensing robot
in Switzerland I thought this was cool
check it out
yeah I just I was looking at that clip I
watched it like a hundred times I
thought it looked amazing and I thought
to myself I want to get one of it one of
those robots for our office not
available not available but I did get my
hands on a much less expensive model
they sell them at Fry's Electronics near
Burbank Airport wasn't that much was
like 600 bucks and I want to get it out
here right now because it's pretty cool
and get some coffee my name is Charlie
the coffee robot
see you there Charlie Charlie tell us
how are you I'm good
would you like some coffee I would love
some coffee right now Charlie we haven't
tried you yet but I want to try you now
and I would love some coffee well grab a
mug and put it under the dispenser don't
be shy
[Applause]
that is
it'll just happen
can I get you some phone no no foam I
don't want any foam and what are these
for these for milk and cream no those
are just my nipples you want to touch it
I really don't I'm good thank you very
much I handy do you want some coffee
yeah sure come on over charlie my name
is Charlie the coffee rose I know I
didn't write some coffee
I would love some coffee I'm a caffeine
addict Charlie grab a mug your flows a
little restricted you might want to get
your prostate checked
ah see Salina Oh body temperature mmm my
favorite yeah one give it up for our
Charlie Charlie that coffee robot
just keep that yeah yeah do not drink
that